tres países en tres días colombia
ecuador y honduras serán las paradas del
corto viaje del presidente del gobierno
de españa' por américa latina' bogotá
será el lugar de partida donde se
reunirá el miércoles y por primera vez
con el recién posesionado presidente
gustavo petro en el palacio de nariño
según fuentes oficiales del ejecutivo
español el acercamiento a venezuela y la
retoma de negociaciones con la guerrilla
de ln formarán parte de los temas de
discusión desde madrid' recalcaron la
importancia de iniciar la relación
política con el nuevo gobierno de
izquierdas que están más alineados con
las ideas progresistas del gabinete de
pedro sánchez su viaje a ecuador y
honduras el jueves y viernes
respectivamente acabará con más de dos
décadas sin que un presidente del
gobierno español visite esos países en
quitó se reunirá con el presidente
ecuatoriano guillermo lasso y en
tegucigalpa con la presidenta xiomara
castró en estos dos países el enfoque
estará más centrado en la cooperación
española y en la migración mientras que
en colombia el enfoque será más que nada
de comercio y de industria sánchez
quiere hacer de la presidencia rotatoria
de la unión europea que españa ostentará
en el último semestre de 2023 la
oportunidad para que él comunitario se
acerque de nuevo a la región sobre todo
porque tal y como sugirió la comisión
europea bruselas siente que está
perdiendo terreno frente a la influencia
de rusia y china- como muestra de esta
voluntad de acercamiento durante la
segunda mitad del año que viene se
celebrará una cumbre unión europea-
celac comunidad de estados
latinoamericanos y caribeños una cita
que no se daba desde 2015